الان اود ان استعرض معكم هذا الفيديو ومن
ثم نستكمل
وا صلوا صلوا
صوتهم
لاحد الشباب يعني لشاب كانت تحت الانقاض
تمكن من الخروج هذا الشاب بعد نحو عشر
ساعات من تحت الانقاض وتمكن من الخروج
لوحده يعني حاول ان يتسلل من بين الانقاض
ثم وصل الى خارج المبنى المدمر اللافت في
هذه الرساله او في هذا الفيديو الذي
شاهدناه دين انه كان يوجه الوصيه الاخيره
لوالده ولاخيه ظنا منه انه هو الذي سيفارق
الحياه لكنه الان هو من هو على قيد الحياه
واخوه ووالده هم الذين فرقوا الحياه ايضا
بالاضافه الى ثمانيه اخرين من عائلته
واخرا به فرق الحياه في وضع ماساوي يمكن
ان يشرحه لنا احمد الان ونستمع اليه نديم
كيف يعني شو اللي صار معكم بالضبط في
البدايه ضرب فينا الزلزال الاول حاولنا
نجتمع كلياتنا قدام الباب تبع البيت عشان
نطلع لبرا ننزل لتحت ما نضل بالبنايه بس
الباب من الزلزال ما حسن لا يفتح ولا
يتحرك حاولنا نكسره انا وخالي اللي اكبر
مني بسنتين كسر حاولنا نضربه بس لكن الباب
ما انفتح وما احسننا نفتحه بقى نحن عم
نحاول ضرب فينا الزلزال الثاني وقعنا
كلياتنا بالزلزال تاني صار في هزازه قويه
وهرت البنايه كامله بالزلزال الثاني وكلكم
مع بعض مين كنتم لكن كلياتنا نحن لما ضرب
الزلزال قعدنا فوق بعض كنا انا
انا وخالي وخالتي وستي ومرت خالي وثلاثه
من بنات خالي واخي واختي وامي وستي
كلياتنا كلياتنا واقفين قدام الباب البيت
عم نحاول نطلع بس لما ضرب الزلزال تاني
بطحنا فوق بعض ووعد فينا البنايه وضليت
انا بعد فتره لحسنت اتحرك يعني ضليت
ساعتين ثلاثه احسنت اتحرك من مكاني كنت ما
اعرف شو وضعي وكان قدامي بنت وراي بنت
قدامي اخي شفت اخي وخالي ومرت خالي وبنات
خالي كمان شفتهم
كلياتهم كان قدامي وبعد فتره حاولت اني
اطلع على الساعه 12:30 حاولت اني اطلع
لبرا باماكن هو انا ما طلعت الا بفضل الله
طلعت من اماكن صغيره وضيقه جدا رح تحسنت
اطلع لفوق اطلب المساعده انه اقول انه في
عايشين كان في شخصين عايشين ما زالوا
عايشين بعدين شو اللي صار كان في اثنين
عايشين لما اجت فرق الانقاذ كان في وحده
علقانه شوي فالله يرحمها ما حسنه تضل
عايشه والثاني انقزوها الحمد لله وعايشه
هي بنت خالي التاني بس سؤال احنا يعني قبل
ما نستخدم هذا الفيديو استاذنك وسالتك اذا
كنت انت بتتحمل او بتشوف هذا الفيديو عندك
ما عندك مشكله فقلت لي انك انت بتشوفه لما
تحضروا الان بعد يعني ثمان ايام من
الحادثه هاي كيف بياثر فيك هذا الفيديو هل
يؤثر فيك هل يعيد هذيك الذكريات لك وبعيد
الذكريات وبياثر بس الواحد لما صار فيه
الزلزال بتحس انه فقط عنده شي من الاحساس
يعني عيلتي كله راحت انا ما ضل عندي حدا
ما ضللي غير خالي وبنت خالي نحن كنا هون
15 شخص ضلينا خمسه
وبنت خالي وابن خالي الثاني ومرته كمان
حامل وضلينا هون لحالنا غالي كان مريض
شكرا
يعني هذه القصه هذا جزء من المعاناه